und trotzdem wünschen wir dass alle die
bisher skeptisch waren sich überzeugen
lassen von uns die sich impfen lassen
haben es ist bei uns gut ausgegangen
betrachtet uns als eure
versuchskaninchen und jetzt macht es ist
zu eurem besten und zum besten eurer
liebsten
tja julian durchaus ehrenwerte absicht
jahren noch mehr menschen dazu zu
bewegen sich impfen zu lassen
schwierige aussage natürlich etwas
unsicherheit damit alle die sich haben
bereits impfen lassen und eigentlich
spielt er auch den querdenkern damit in
den pass man sagt ja so schön der weg
zur hölle ist gepflastert mit guten
absichten und das was olaf scholz hier
gesagt hat ist glaube ich dafür ein sehr
gutes beispiel was er sagen wollte es
ist doch alles gut gegangen was er
gesagt hat man hat millionen menschen
und das ist ja genau der vorwurf den
querdenker immer wieder erheben zu eben
versuchskaninchen
eines impfstoffs der nicht ausreichend
erforscht ist gemacht dazu muss man ganz
klar sagen das wort versuchskaninchen
ist ja aus zwei gründen vollkommen
unangebracht erstens gab es ja klinische
studien zu diesem impfstoff man wusste
dass dieser impfstoff funktioniert man
wusste dass dieser impfstoff keine
dramatische nebenwirkungen hat wir waren
also ausdrücklich nicht die
versuchskaninchen dieses wort zu nennen
ist absolut verheerend in einer phase in
der wir noch wollen dass mehr menschen
sich impfen lassen damit sagt man und
bestätigt man genau das was es als
vorwurf zu oft gegeben hat zweiter punkt
ist einfach der
blick auf menschen insgesamt im
wahlkampf millionen menschen als
versuchskaninchen zu bezeichnen ist
finde ich grundsätzlich auch eine
problematische sicht auf die dinge ich
käme nicht einmal auf den gedanken
menschen in diese reihe einzuordnen und
ich glaube das ist ein wort was olaf
scholz im wahlkampf noch oft hören wird
und was das kann man sagen sein erster
großer patzer in diesem wahlkampf ist
das wort versuchskaninchen hätte niemals
fallen dürfen und das hören wir auch aus
spd kreisen dass man dort nicht
besonders glücklich ist über dieses wort
hier entspannt hat sich natürlich sofort
dazu geäußert und jetzt steht der
vorwurf im raum die menschen die sich
jetzt nicht mehr impfen lassen wollen
die noch nicht geimpft und ich nicht
mehr impfen lassen wollen die können
doch ganz legitim sagen der
kanzlerkandidat sagt ich bin ein
versuchskaninchen
ich möchte aber kein versuchskaninchen
sein bald auch in dem stoff für euch